Bachelorette Hana one guy is already
declared his love for her after just 24
hours we've all been there right yeah
right i lauren zima was with Hanna today
Luke P said he was starting to fall in
love with you I'm starting to fall I was
like oh god he's saying it Oh God are
you really saying that yep you said it
at the end of the night I started
questing in a little bit too we side of
all real quick - a little shirtless
moment last night oh yeah that Luke's
declaration of love isn't the only drama
unfolding this season judging by this
teaser at ABARES Hannah was sex shamed
on her own show
Jesus still loves me it seems like you
felt judged or shame it's like
regardless of any thing that I've done
it that people might think oh well that
deserves a scarlet letter that's not how
it works
nobody's gonna judge me I won't say
where I'm gonna speak my mind
well you know we just interviewed Chris
Harrison he told us he wasn't sure if
this season would end in a proposal why
would he say that look I will be the
first to say that I was a pain in the
butt to deal with and I had a lot of
breakdowns and it was yeah it was a
really hard time
[Music]